hey everybody chris waters here hosting
multiple players i have multiple players
on the couch with me one of them is
daniel dwyer what's up hey danny how you
doing what's going on uh maxwell mcgee
howdy howdy sean mcginnis
got great teeth uh and we're playing
screen sheet the premise of this game is
it's a four player split screen fps in
which all of the characters are
invisible and therefore you have to
screen cheat i.e look at your on your
other player screens to know where they
are and then subsequently kill them this
is like it's like goldeneye but but
not but you have to 24 so you're
supposed to be making a confession here
i screen cheated all the time when i
played goldeneye because i didn't even
hear the term screen sheet until i went
to college because it wasn't a thing
people didn't get like like in the house
that i played goldeneye my house there
was no house of waters and people would
be like stop looking at my screen and i
was like
this is my house you can see my screen
as easily as i can see yours there's
skill in interpreting interactions
it's all fair in love and war so what
you're saying is you were operating on a
higher level of golden eye efficiency i
like to think so then these plebeians
they stuck you with well yes in not so
many words uh what are your what were
your experiences with the screen
cheating or not what do we got i was all
about screen cheating i mean that was
another thing we never because people
talk about how they get like the
cardboard thing and you tape it up
no no no no no look it's it's the game
is what it is screen chaining is just a
part of it when i played under the
tournament with my friend we'd land and
i'd always set it up so i had like a
mirror that i could oh what
what
oh that's gross oh taking it it's gross
the next level he's not like that
love life
sean you oh yeah yeah you have to adapt
to the circumstances that's right and in
that day and age split screen was how it
was i had sorry you just roll that one
just roll that way unless like some
twitter users including fob washed you
got good at just looking down all the
time oh my god and then popping up when
you were going to kill someone like they
used to navigate goldeneye
it's terrible it's terrifying you don't
have to do it in this game in this game
it's just uh look at the other person's
screen and shoot them [ __ ] uh now we're
we're the players uh benito has arranged
it so we're all each in our window i'm
here and uh see i'm over here and so
this is the map and it's just as just a
death match so we're gonna try to
come on oh you want a piece of this come
get it i am here i'm here to go get it
hunky oh yeah well [ __ ] you got word so
uh somebody walk up the stairs so i can
shoot you in the face
[ __ ] we're right beside each other i'm
trying to do the stair at the floor
stretching it's not working this isn't
working at all it's a horrible plan so
you can see that like oh god my grenade
launchers floors are different colors oh
jesus boom to try to get you to
oh
to like so you can eat it or easily
identify where people are there's like
landmarks around
and yeah it also has these like
different phrases for whenever you kill
someone
um this is stressful
yeah i know
this is a game that like wants to make
you paranoid i think oh that's nice
yes
what the shh besieged i was looking at
for a second i was like simeon who is oh
wait that's sean
you can go for a candelabra why would i
use this i can i can't you can't choose
your weapon a second time can you you
can when you respawn right but then once
you've respawned yeah so i'm stuck with
this [ __ ] candelabra well here's the
thing about the candelabra is it it's a
higher rate of fire because you don't
have to do anything all right because
these are old tiny weapons and you have
to remove that okay well somebody's
played the game before i have played the
game before we played it during comic
con to see if it would work out for uh
multiple players yo get off the [ __ ]
score screen chris and maxwell quit
screen cheating chris
what's uh 30 30 000. i think it only
goes up to 10 10 it is is there more
than one map yes but we're not going to
do that just yet because there's two
maps
got to tease that out yeah he's always
gonna have to stay tuned for that other
map coming up later in the stream half
an hour
all right
here we go
okay get ready for a hot candelabra
attack oh my gosh
yeah
eat that
dude oh i couldn't can't fast enough
pete candelabra op are you candelabra oh
yeah back to back all day
i'm about that
candelabra action boss oh [ __ ] looking
at two things at once it's so hard i got
killed i killed you with my [ __ ] gun
that shoots a volvo rifle it's called a
grenade launcher a grenade gun it's
called a grenade it's a weird launcher
come here i know where you are and i'm
chasing you and i'm going to murder you
you just shot me right in the face
my windows visted maxwell
all right i'm using the revolver rifle
which is actually
pretty like it's more of a precision
weapon it's a revolving door you guys
don't know where i am do you i guess it
is called the river in the purple room
you're in the sex pest room oh get dead
wait where'd you go
yeah
oh i got spunked you spunked on me
how about you suck on this you're just
in there swinging that candelabra oh
yeah buddy yeah why not i hate sean
mckenna this is just your sweet sweep
though let's sweep
my problem is i'm only ever looking at
sean's screen because i just want to
murder him well that's
how it always goes
don't you come up here
hold it oh now i'm gonna kill you while
you reload your dumb baby gun
it's the kind of gun a baby would use
that's all i only do
baby murders with
what are you talking about my baby
burger gun
you guys got one of those all right no
babies have enemies not rifle anymore
you should use this
oh i just like i was just gonna wander
up into it just like whatever
let's just go see what that's all about
oh what up this is amazing
i'm on a friggin
kill streak here
i'm streaking
with
i was scream watching when you killed me
so i thought that i'd kill someone i was
wrong
oh you're gonna suck oh
damn it i saw your size keys
that was something scheming i was up
there scheming [ __ ] candelabra guy
i turn around where's where are you see
that grenade hit me in the face
oh [ __ ] come here
get it
where'd you go
oh
nice work maxwell you killed yourself
gg gg maxwell
on that one there we go there we go
got that spare i think i'm the best at
this now
it's okay
oh gotcha yeah
i got deep fried by butts is what the
screen does
oh how would that even work
seriously how would that how would you
get deep fried biscuits i'll see you up
there yeah that was a dinosaur
great work
there's another mode hold my danny yep
hold my danny 45 kills to win oh man
this map unlocks the the higher kill
limit actually it's not a new map it's a
new mode what whoa
what
hill campers king of the hill oh this is
going to be great this is going to be
real good i'm taking the grenade
launcher jerks where's the hill
oh yeah that [ __ ] hit oh yeah
where's the hill oh wait am i yeah is
the hill the bones yeah
the hell was the bones
oh no oh you got to stay up there with
the bones yeah you got to climb on them
bones
i'm in the hill now he'll move
oh can you see me when i'm in the hill
no welcome to let's all log grenades
into the hills
i got kanye west
kim kardashian went down on you
by you
but your agency somehow oh no
i enabled it to happen
oh
double kale whoa
eat it
the hills
suck it down whoa
see auntie on sean scouts
yeah 11 there is this game in beta
yes you're in beta this game is invader
ah suicide she shot you jerk face
suck it down
where's the hill now oh now it's just
guys where's the
what accent is that
are these australians i don't know i did
get turned on to this game by james
cozzanet you got turned on by james
cousins
join
rich coming i want to go wire but
ah i got virus kind of i see on
i just don't want to wink in a hillywood
i was going to just keep grenading the
[ __ ] hill area and ruining all your
birthday parties oh that's ruined my
birthday party i got space jammed
do your dance eat that y'all bunch of
shits
space jack i can't get up to the top of
the dino
am i in my
yeah the hill moved
take me to that funky town
[ __ ]
why because i have the grenade launcher
and i need to not use it here here we go
blunderbuss always uses the grenade
launcher the problem is whenever i kill
everyone in the area i end up killing
myself too like an idiot
you're just an idiot that's why the hill
is moving oh no
i got a blunder boner
but seriously what is a blunder boner
i'll tell you later okay
kinda loud bro's in here i can tell
wait
get out of here candelabra in a blunder
boner underboner is when you
got shanked by butts so you accidentally
sit on it
yourself
oh and you sit on your own yeah oh boy
that's the worst anyways video games
dang it ah the dinosaur contact lens is
coming out either because it hates my
blunder boner joke
probably
really popular downside the hill is
controlled
how about you eat on my how about you
put your teeth around this blunderbuss
and i pulled the trigger
does all these characters even have
teeth i think that was
a ponytail
it's a great way of killing everyone
including yourself yeah a bunch of
people out there the hill is controlled
oh you want to
control that hill not belong jerk dong
face oh oh no i got nasty butts
all i do is run in and kill everyone
including myself yeah and don't get any
points how it's done the hill has moved
the hill is controlled like that's the
on i got down
i know that's my favorite spot right by
the mammoth bud
like this some might call it the butt
crack
this is the worst possible gun to have
here
touched by danny
he's really pulling out a lead here
i'll take that deep fries
that's good that hand's moving the
minute i got in there so i'm not going
to bother you got a 360 mlg no scope
oh yeah big time
why don't you get dead
the hill has moved i got uninstalled
gonna do it better hey sean what's it
like to be sucking right now ah
whoever's walk up the stairs i'm sorry
the hill is controlled
the hill is controlled double kill the
hill is a double kill
yes i just realized i spent the past 10
minutes only looking on my screen
yeah that's the wrong way to do it
that's probably why i'm so
depressingly
in fourth place at the moment i could
not be more in fourth place right now
you killed me when i was but moments
away from the winning i got some points
[ __ ]
44 to 44 red and green who's it gonna be
who's gonna get the last oh yeah oh
camping that he'll spawn
look at that
gg sean and also you other guys who were
in this game apparently i was really bad
look at all those kills danny got yeah
that was uh
i was playing my own game that was a hot
garbage performance
all right
should we do it should we play another
map
do we want to play that card so early
yes no yes yes
okay
oh [ __ ] it's gardening
don't mind overdue let's yeah let's
start with hill camping oh you guys hey
hill camping is so high pressure it's
really high pressure let's make a little
fast 25 yeah fast-paced hill camping
it'll
that's what it's called
can we send it to one can we do sudden
death yeah let's do some sudden death
yeah let's try it congratulations
i feel good about my
oh this is difficult now because oh this
is difficult now look at this
i want to go right in there just just
firing into the sky disproved global
warming
no but he like it's like it's echoing or
something like he doesn't he won't shut
up
double kill
i got munch
got a little bug no that's good
it's good how is this a bug i'm kind of
into it how is this no this is really
good no matter what it keeps replacing
repeating so he says the hill is moved
the hill is moving the hill is removed
he's still so surprised
haven't you ever played a first person
shooter and wondered what would happen
if the announcer had a stroke
i played video games where i think the
designers had a stroke
as well
i have a stroke you mean
that's what i mean obviously
double kill
hey did anyone get a double kill
i got one point
the halo just keeps moving
that's literally literally the whole
point of the game yeah
head in the game thing
there we go shoot into the floor
everybody i know
getting ahead in the game
did you catch my address
i'm just going to stand up on the
highest point and just fire this grenade
yeah i'm going to win the
clever game again i'm second i'm
actually not doing that terribly this
time
this is the best bug ever i love it
i love it i love it more than anything
bug or feature eat that river doge ouch
river dongs it's got man cannons
vis-a-vis double kills
i guess what's it called when you like
kill two other players at the same time
is it like a twice twice kill twice over
a two kill we're really close sean
literally just has to own the hill i
know and it's been that way for like
five minutes you've had a lot of chances
ah it always moves just when i get
towards it
let's just deny
you
him
just go in there and just detonate
themselves so that they can't get it
don't you dare share this at anyone's
house i killed myself like a jerk
no
no
let's see if it's going to go away
by double kill guys us
ends our life a legacy national
nightmare of double kills let's go back
to the yes
let's do this
here we
that's you danny by the way that's what
you look like in real life oh oh let's
do it here we go
mirrors have been lying this way that's
my mental game
[ __ ] sitting there thinking what what
did you think big plans
big ideas are you scheming where are you
suck on that
look at johnny not moving over there
[ __ ] happening over in red oh
i was trying to kill that guy
who is that
ceo oh it's maxwell oh don't come up in
my face maxwell's going for some sort of
a
like
not shoot anyone tactic just terrifying
oh he can make he's a conscientious
objector
i see you down by that
little sewer grate
let me use the force
the forks and use the force who's the
forks luke
from downtown oh
dag
are you guys just all grenade launchers
oh yeah you just look what color they're
in and then just chuck grenades in that
general direction or do what i do and
just don't bother looking
that's a pretty good uh
what are we playing too yes eat that
sean you
yeah it's happening to you buddy yeah
that's right maxwell
nope oh yeah
get butts
all the way up
that's all the way all right here we go
that's all the way here in screen sheet
uh
shooting the hell out of this game
yep yep all right i'm going to win this
one
bold claims with a candelabra
we should do an all candelabra match
soon
yes sean what just happened to you
you i got killed
specifically well let's not go into
details
i feel like our audience deserves to
know
nobody deserves to know i'm just
shooting in the purple because i see a
lot of purple oh yeah you saw a lot of
purple
what that's your face yeah there you go
nailed it and that's keep ldg here
hashtag nailed it
oh my god oh my goodness we're marvel
come and get you that's what killed you
scion
there it is
maxwell won [ __ ] those jump pads or
something we
jesus
oh jesus
i'll take the lord's name in vain oh
windows visted
can you see the vista here oh
maxwell mcdead
[ __ ]
whoa
oh it's blocked i got splunked by butts
yeah
i'm gonna try the
rifle
oh no
god
you missed me with your right i missed
that was my blunderborks i have uh your
boots oh
my gosh that was a mid-air shot baby
we talk about how all the weapons have
flags hanging from them to show your
color just in case
360 mlg no scope
you can't even chris you can't call it
no scoping if there's literally no scope
option in the game also there's no scope
there is no scope i mean it's right
just because every kill is by definition
no scoping implies that scoping is also
an option for you to do i mean i guess
so otherwise it's just a basic type kill
that's my favorite kind
bam get pee wind
puned
[ __ ]
there somewhere yeah i see you i see you
up there don't come get it
come on
okay oh god no
oh
hashtag dead i'm going back to my
blunderbuss there's some crazy
candelabra around here where are you at
where are you at stop it i'm gonna find
you you are not gonna candelabra you are
not no i have a very particular set of
skills
you are not and those include
candlelockering people i have a very
particular series
i was trying to hunt you
great work butts
do you guys like just do some quick i
got more kills than all of you combined
yeah i just want to point that out
checks out but wait no there's i wasn't
the only one who had a notable round
sean had more deaths than everyone else
combined you died loads like an idiot
yeah i died a lot
i certainly i died a significant number
we need to do that we need to do that
all can't yeah
it looks like my chances of going
professional and screen sheet are pretty
slim going all right this is a
candelabra match
in which oh this is all candles all
players all lobs pick candelabra at the
start all candelabra pick candelabros
it's pretty good what it's called guys
you can have that one for free kind of
we got are we all locked in
we're locked in on lobber mode whoa i
got creamed by starting off
wow
sean you know how you were commenting
about the uh color of the flags hanging
from your gun yeah note the color of the
candles
yeah i know oh [ __ ]
next level part of me feels like there's
a lot of good work going on like your
character should like flicker a little
bit when you fire your weapon oh you i
mean you can see a swipe of candelabra
flame
but that's the only when you find no
when you when you fire a weapon you can
see the smoke coming as well oh yeah
that's true
maxwell you got deep fried i think i'm
just going to target you
i'm just going to watch your screen and
not really worry about what i'm just
running around the map swinging
i just hope you hit something yep i
don't mean the law of averages right
i think that's how science works
purple the red red the bench there it is
he's muttering to himself landmarks of
my progress i don't know about that
all right somebody's by the horse nope
not anymore yeah
come on down come on purple gold come
here come on down to funky tail no you
just ran right you're gonna get it
my way or the highway come on up come on
up i know you want it max well i do
want to come and get it
let's just be our final battle
suck it down
danny comes in with a spoiler i got a
kill
my first killer game i'm the best
great work danny
oh come on
sean's doing the
one of you is doing the old oh max why
are you coming you're coming after me
yeah that's right press x to jason
jason
jose jason jason double k jason double
jason double kale joyson whoa jesus
that's funny because they made a joke
about press exegetion but that's that
broken bug is kind of what happened in
this game earlier
that's it that was it right there
hey it's screeching it's in beta
i
got justified
like
center justified or like right justified
oh like like
the award-winning album oh justified
like more like the show you're now
starring timothy oliphant and it's
pronounced elephant
tim elephants it's an elephant hitman
yeah let's do this
maxwell
we meet again on the field battle tim
oliphant as tobias reaper
oh oh you get that oh
don't worry i i avenged your death chris
thanks you came in there for scraps yeah
i came in well it's not so much scraps
as it is oh dang it eat it danny oh i
see i see you coming i see you coming
you want a piece of this
this is intense come on
i'm going to [ __ ] get in the mix over
there let's see what happens come get
try it
wild card car maneuver oh who's in it
who's in oh i'm cleaning house i'm
cleaning the house
oh you got books all right everyone meet
in red
everybody go right i'm eating red i'm
going to red no don't leave me out i'm
getting left out all right which red am
i in i don't know there's one right are
you colorblind
boom boom
oh you guys are in the grass
in the weeds
down in the weeds oh yeah yeah i get it
you guys in the weeds all right in the
weeds
hey wait a minute wait a minute who's
got the gun oh he's got the gun
you can use it you can use a gun
that's right
screen sheet the game's about cheating
[ __ ] oh you son of a [ __ ] you son of a
[ __ ] why did i ruin christmas for the
mckinseys did i yeah you did again great
again
you ruined christmas and you mentioned
timothy oliver i didn't mention timothy
ellison reminded me of that that was
hitman movie
listen
to the olympian in which the
well-meaning prostitute helps him murder
people
in the elephants because hollywood is a
great hooker with a heart of gold
heart of gold and a pocket full of
condoms
yeah used
these condoms yeah
they're collector's items
what you don't she's she's a broker
she's paranoid and she thinks that the
government are going to try and steal
her identity which is why she
she keeps the pockets
uh
sometimes you just gotta hold on to all
your jimmy hats
you never know
i feel bad now about the thing i didn't
think i'd have the grenade don't feel
that long yeah you should feel bad
because you're doing and yet you're only
winning by one point how does that was
it
i'm going to kill myself and go back to
candelabra so i can win with a
candelabra and therefore be the best and
a giant asterisk yeah
such an asterisk as there never was on a
man
wow that was jesus
all right
all right see you later
you're our great blue hope maxwell
you can do this i'm just watching i'm
just
exclusively watching this is a huge
piece of [ __ ]
oh you want to do this come get let's do
this get it come get it oh yeah that's
that's right that's right your body is
sunk your body that is the candelabra of
karma smiting down upon thee
i came last no i didn't no i came in
last i thought i was last this entire
thing because it keeps
we'll be back with more screen sheet and
more custom modes for danny to totally
cheat at
all right the next game match
revolvers only
hill camping in the garden
choose those revolvers and then get to
slinging it's all because i mentioned
timothy oliphant isn't it guys yeah yep
did you know what to buy a sweeper named
his guns
i don't know who tobias rebirth hitman's
real [ __ ] name i did not know which
one is the sixth shooter
it's the revolver rifle
yeah yeah he named his guns they're
called hugging and kissing
are you trying to cross map blast me
over there
one of them is called butt hugging
yeah the other one's called butt
chugging
gross hey guys we're talking
exhilarating
the reload time on this thing is [ __ ]
oh i blasted you from so far away
that's more revolver technique
son of a dick
yikes we all danny see this i'm just i'm
cleaning house here stop trying to shoot
me from over there max
20 seconds to win
i clean the house
the hill is missing
you guys you guys the hell is moving
the hill is controlled [ __ ] it
i formatted butts
it takes so long to reload my antique
victorian
i was just hitting it
oh somebody died and tea bagged me yeah
that's me
died as i lived
screaming
nards ah
open season on sean mcinnis
the hill has moved the hills
hey guys i think the hell is moved oh
you get dead mother [ __ ]
mommy what's a mother [ __ ]
the minute i got there
get punched
y'all some [ __ ]
i got on the board
oh you finally got a point i got on the
board great work buddy just joining the
game here in the olympics
really embarrassing for everyone
involved this this current situation
listen the hill has moved guys
[ __ ] it dude suck it dude circuit dune
the hill is controlled
it was a move [ __ ] i went the wrong way
no it says deep fried i mean unless
that's what you unless you have the
other review
the game provides you
you don't need to
go directly into
this is how world war ii started people
i'm just shooting from across the map
because you guys are like a big old
turkey shoot
[ __ ] you truly assure destruction i
picked blunderbuss back
the hill has moved the hill has moved
the hill they could have just called
this game the kill has moved you know
you try to have a gentleman's agreement
but you don't play with gentlemen and
that's what you get yeah that's what
happens are you dweebs we're going back
to dino land
for the map
dino and it's gonna be a straight up
shooting shooting shoot
wait what did you want to play did you
want to drop out oh i want to play video
game what are the rules of this
news go back
go back
type in my name say it's danny the best
why are you cheating a bag
danny's really cheating a bag on this
one it's gonna be death match
and uh what's the weapon type i don't
know
let's go candelabros again yeah i really
like camera oh your candle bros
that includes cheating a bag
cheating a bag
candelabras
okay
where are y'all some [ __ ] are kicking
in like that look at these funky time
beats
double kill
is it a party in purple over there
it's a birth party purple party get
ready for a hot party
man i'm on a kill streak here
must really suck to be dying and my
hands consistent
oh
you're gonna get your missile strike
double kill double kill the hill has
moved the hill has moved
double kill
all
red time oh you want this
party oh
no you double kill each other i double
killed both of them oh i want to kill
maxwell as well see
me everyone's getting murdered by me
yeah you're having a great match
irish were fighting for independence
they used to use candelabras so it's in
my jeans that's true
we used to eat candelabras
the great candelabra famine of the 19th
century the blight as we call it the
candelabra blight
right
right oh
i signed out
but
oh you wanna all right coming in come on
in come on in
come to my house
you coming to my house are you swinging
a cantilever at me you think you can
just
oh [ __ ] yeah yeah that's my plan
actually
all right
danny's one away from victory
not this one danny
you're riverdark i'm gonna be me oh [ __ ]
you get two of them
oh yeah
cheating a bag
i want to get come on
yeah i did screenshot you that time
i knew you were coming down i was like
if i just get around the corner oh
that was really good danny cheating the
bag cheating
cheated that bad look what happened when
i stopped cheating it was a son of a gun
that's victorious
let's do another one with grenades only
because it's a real [ __ ] show right oh
yeah grenades only and
uh
hello campers
that's gonna go very well
i'm gonna be cheating the bag so hard
he's gonna go candelabra op and just
shred us all all right
here we go grenades for everyone
yo guys the hill has moved
hey there it is why did he say it it
didn't move get off my [ __ ] dino hold
my dino
ah i got you
butts river dogs
i just bounced my grenade off of some
weird dino
maxwell oh i'm controlling the [ __ ] out
of this hill
you can just call me
i got a point i don't know i used a comp
controller i don't have zero points
great work not zero points guys
oh you totally yeah come on down guys
come on down the way
yeah damn it double kayla
oh kill myself see you later i
you you're in the way
thanks obama
i'm glad you're on top of that with me
oh yeah don't worry about that
oh
oh the hell has moved danny cds
oh i got swagged
all of you can suck on that one
great work cheating only two of them
this is a misinformation campaign
i don't know what to believe anymore
i got all so disillusioned
i was disillusioned with the modern hill
system
oh everyone died there except me i did a
suicido
[ __ ] you're we were right on top of you
oh crap
that was not a good show jesus
come on
that was really good
or until we go [ __ ] mental because of
this guy
because that's coming up
whoa
you got me you got me there cheating
bags
moves the hills [ __ ]
yeah it's the best because every time
you shoot there you know it's going to
hit someone because everyone's always
lying
oh this is so tense
now i know how the olympians feel
the hill
they never know when it might things
might explode i'm gonna win on the dyno
oh no you aren't
done
downstairs there's a there's a screen
all right not last i'm holding strong at
not last i'm holding strong
onto your butt
what up
what a cheating a bag
over here sorry from space lol in the
twitch chat this game is screen cheats
it's actually one word uh
you might have confused it for that
wildly popular game the hill has moved
the hill has moved the hill has moved
the hill has moved the hill has moved
the hill has moved i want to do a double
kill
kill double kill the hill has moved the
hill has moved the hill has moved double
whoops
what are we doing i don't know i think
lisa needs braces double kill
lisa needs braces double kill
watch pick whatever you want
because i'm picking grenade launcher
then
are you right here
oh
get bust
get butt take you to school by
riding a blunderbuss
you're the worst yeah cause that was a
real elaborate
this guy sitting on the [ __ ] oh
someone is straight collaborating
oh a double kill that's right oh
double kill i am working all you open oh
my goodness i just blanked all of you
into five kills oh yeah in a five kill
match yeah someone said someone said
you're like from that time you guys got
zero kills the whole match
oh hey chris have you heard of small
sample size
in statistics no because i haven't uh
seen your doctor
nailed it now he's talking about your
dick nailed it
oh maxwell you know i'm trying to get
tricky over here but he doesn't know
where he is you know what's happening
okay i can't be trusted with the i got
to go back on a bus all right
but seriously
chris and i have the same dentist and he
talks about chris's small penis all the
time
it's weird i need a new dentist listen
i have this thing at my dentist
he just likes to talk about it and i get
i get a great discount
because he knows i could sue him so bad
but he gave me like three teeth oh it's
been great he gave you free teeth
whitening did you say your dentist who
touches your penis gave you a free time
no he doesn't touch it yeah it's not
weird he just it's not a weird thing
when you say teeth whitening yeah
ah
teeth whitening
i feel like a lot of your innuendo is
just failing to understand basic
concepts in the world
it's a good guy ah teeth whitening
i fetished maxwell
gross [ __ ] i see you i got viruses in my
butt do you see me like like like jake
sully
negative one excellent that's right well
because i suicided myself that one time
that is that's an act that's accurate
actually
wow my goodness did we all get four
deaths though in that one
except for i don't know me because i'm
just way better than you just like in
life
you only get four you only get four
all right let's go back to the gardens
straight up that much
what do you want you want to call
something else straight up that match
all right
straight death matching
count my own baby look at that thing get
death that was a bear
my first death match right
come on bro
you get killed
oh wow converted maxwell you're ready
you're ready now
oh the grenade launcher also has a
lingering yeah uh like smoke from the
muzzle
so it's not just the moment that you
fire it it's a little bit afterwards
crap
vengeance is yours maxwellian indeed
vengeance is not yeah there's like a
little wisp
suck it down suck it down
anyone hanging out along the perp that
perp tip
absolutely
just
he's weak he's way too close cannot
allow oh
y'all both get [ __ ] exploded
but seriously one of you has to die i
have zero points
can one of these yes could one of you
just exactly do an exchange yeah do you
want to just what how did i miss that
show
eat it maxwell now danny's the only one
without any murder points not yet dick i
just killed you
fair enough
we all
cherish it
nourish it in your heart bear [ __ ] in
your heart of hearts
by the time i realized something was
wrong the entire town was infested with
zombies
i got swag by sean
it's pronounced oh
oh that was a directional
spawn camper it did not how can you
spawn cabinet oh yeah
that maxwell situation i'm gonna hang
out got a real maxwell situation i would
watch a tv show there we go the maxwell
situation
situation
you need to talk about max
and then i would do a critical piece on
it called what people talk about when we
talk about maxwell's such a camera i
don't think i'd wanna you're the corner
then you are
everyone's just camping in the corners
oh yeah they're called pro strats
it's called hashtag mlg no scope yeah
i could not close the game
i'm just i'm just i'm going to send kids
my kids to college on the bones of sean
mcginnis
hello
i don't
i would like to learn here i don't have
any money but i do have these bonuses
you have these human bones
do you take human bones
i would like one education please i
don't know maybe some eccentric
millionaire would like them you could
sell them to them
[ __ ] music
come on
chris you suck you're gonna line me up
you think you're gonna line me up
that's copyright infringement yeah video
game developers come on i think
i mean cool
that's cool
all right my latest tactic is just
picking one dude and just
that's what maxwell's been doing to me
for the whole
strategy huh
i wonder why sean keeps dying
oh you don't want to do that pursuit
i game where you is i cheated the [ __ ]
out of that all the time oh yeah
oh my gosh
oh my god oh you bad i can't get inside
your head
where you at danny where are you at
see now i'm not hunting you oh my god
that was incredible yeah
wow
oh maxwell and i are in the land of many
colors
oh no oh no oh i fell grenade party
coming your way
[ __ ]
axel we gotta get out of here i know we
gotta bail somebody's coming to ruin the
party
wow hey how come you guys didn't invite
me oh my god guys i have a grenade
he didn't invite me i'm gonna tell my
mom
boom
grace on his back great work all right
we got time for one more match one more
match oh you signed them all yes i was
so close i was so close eight of those
were sean mechanics one was a mishit
when i killed one of you i really killed
a lot of sean
how could eight of them be mine if i
only died seven times danny the math
doesn't add up the numbers don't work
oh that's gonna be it i like how we each
picked nemesis that time and just like
didn't kill others oh [ __ ] i picked the
wrong gun like an aegis
oh what this isn't my [ __ ] grenade
launcher this is a [ __ ] guy you guys
are all about that nato's i'm all about
that
boss or nothing
nader dots
where are you at homie
oh i see it oh
touche i think that's a song
population you yeah a lonely town
also
other people throughout history that'll
be really depressing oh yeah
all right back to grenade launcher it is
[ __ ] i killed myself instantly great all
that work for nothing
when you chose his next day
you king chode
the king of the chodes
danny o'dwyer
i'll take that
king of the chodes yeah better to be
king of something you know
yeah better be the king of oh i killed
myself again come on i was coming in to
do those trucks better be the king of
choke town
mayor of town
at all
better to have chewed and lost
after the two have never choked at all
at all that's what my dad told me yep
when i when i asked why my penis was so
wide oh my goodness
candid conversations in the odd
household
really not prepared for this
no
this always happens when we end up being
on a stream
awful
yeah becomes like a pop-up video of
weird crap that's happened to danny in
his life yeah oh it's a weird situation
one time i asked my dad about my penis
oh i got obama
thanks obama got elected to the
opposition
damage i gotta you got hashtag yolo'd i
did
i got
you
much
you're just a real sucky [ __ ] guy but
that might hit you
you missed
come on
i got crunk by cheetah maxwell
which one's max again the one swinging
the candle obviously yeah he's like a
maniac big time candle opera guy
get that maxwell you should call me that
in high school
big time candle lobber guy yeah yeah
yeah i mean big time
i
candle
landed on your dome and splattered it
open
the ladies used to call him big time
candelabra guy yeah you catch my drift
yeah
it forks in a weird way
it's because of his forked fiery penis
and it shoots fire yeah it's actually
pretty boss when you think about it but
it's also very ornate
it's very ornate
there's a little engraving on the side
yeah
you know when we all get fired next week
i feel like as far as
i feel like when tom mcshey he was
supposed to be on the stream but a
conflict came up and so he couldn't come
but then
i invited danny on
and got myself into a worse situation
yeah yeah i can't remember
that was a real out of the frying pan
and into the fire situation
come on die
oh i see you hanging out by that
pretty
i scream watching so much i didn't
realize that maxwell had murdered me
totally oblivious to it oh that's such
an absolute nonsense [ __ ]
nonsense [ __ ] it's the worst kind of
[ __ ] that's why they start feeding
you that nonsense [ __ ] come here
maxwell you get away
oh like the predator oh that was such
horseshit
you were not aiming for me no i was just
shooting randomly i'll be honest with
you but a point to point danny
i was just shooting randomly yeah no
there it is there it is
psychic you're like that psychic yeah
like that oh
that was
freaking good
candelabra guy but
yeah it says it on screen because i won
and that is what my steam name is for
some weird reason i don't know i'm an
adult
oh
screen cheat it's on steam right now in
beta i don't know if you can
download it they better add some new
modes and levels all right i think it's
coming out soon hopefully there's going
to be some more maps but kind of fun as
a concept that's good kind of kind of
good for a live stream when you want to
talk about candelabros
uh thanks for playing guys
thank you thank you chris yeah real good
good work good work maxwell my honorary
nemesis of the show
uh
tomorrow morning what do we got sean on
the show
there's that new uh gta 4 pc graphics
mod that came out last week
and i was like that seems like a good
really flimsy excuse to play gta 4. 11
a.m pacific and then on the lob oh we've
got a the last of us remastered and
we're gonna have some comic con stuff oh
fireball
firefall
come on back tomorrow and check this out
guys uh in the meantime thanks for
watching have a great night
see ya see ya another time multiple
players